[Musique]
l'armée rouge aura encore bien d'autres
guerres à mener on a besoin de temps que
pour gagner devrait être capable de
résister aux flammes de l'enfer
une tonne et demie de gasoil par tant qu
on en portera des barils sur les blindés
on accumule les kilomètres on teste les
machines et on prouve la qualité du
savoir-faire soviétique où vous les
faire traverser la moitié du pays à deux
prototypes de chars d'assaut top secret
sans validation de la mission mon
service s'y opposera vous pouvez
considérer que vous avez mon accord le
projet étant top secret il apporte que
votre mission le soit aussi
[Musique]
kharkov
moscou la distance parfaite pour tester
les machines
cette nouvelle technologie russe
pourrait nous causer bien des embarras
ces deux engins doivent disparaître
allez vassili démarche
[Musique]
mettez vous à l'abri
comment se peut-il qu'un groupe de
spécialistes extrêmement bien entraînés
qui se bat contre cinq civils soient
mises en échec il faut appeler l'armée
oui vas-y allez vas-y ombrelle fois
[Musique]